we're going to start out by going over
one of my games played a couple of years
ago and this game is my opponent play
the Kings Indian defense so the topic
will be how to play against the Kings
Indian defense if you are a default
player you open up with d4
this system is very very interesting and
I've been playing it for many years and
it's a positional system but you can get
some interesting positions so Knight f6
c4g 693 Bishop g7 and then the most
popular movies efore here but we're not
going to play that with de 9 f3 can also
be showed g5 anybody familiar with the
system or you know the name for this
what is it called okay this is a called
as Smith's love world champion was
vasily smyslov and Petrossian these are
the two exhorted champions former world
champions that played this a lot and
I've been playing it the system you know
probably the past 15 years using it
against the Kings Indian defense so I
have lots of experience played against
many strong players so this game my
opponent is a strong player 2500 fidei
as a international massive ego foil girl
and he you know he always played the
Kings Indian defense so he played a lot
circulate d6
actually III the idea behind the system
is that you just want to develop your
pieces without allowing them to attack
in the center and the main lines
basically when you play E for it's very
sharp
you play E for the main line for example
is d6 we should be to e5 Castle this is
just an example the you know you can
play before it's called the bionet
attack and basically black ghost 9 h5
and white tries to advance the spawns on
the queenside
meantime black is trying to play a 5 on
it so it's kind of a race where if
you're not careful with white you can
very easily get checkmated so this is
very complicated and you know you're the
player with black pieces understands how
to play this position better then the
player with the white this is this could
be trouble
so the system that I'm going to be
showing you today avoids all this
because first of all you're not going to
be under attack because you put the pawn
only three and this way you keep this
Bishop you try to keep the special
restricted because Kings Indian players
they normally like to play complicated
positions and try to have some attacking
chances by by playing like this you
eliminate that so now it's not so clear
now how black can try to attack white is
just playing very solidly so now my
opponent played 90 d7 I go B should be
to c6 and Queen C to see if you look at
the position you would think the most
natural move here is to castle but here
the best move would be to play Queen c2
first because you set up a little trap
Queen anyway belongs on c2 in this
position by playing this move now if
your opponent plays h6
trying to chase the bishop you go back
to h4 9 goes g5 attacking the bishop and
this is a pretty common idea even a lot
of grandmasters they try to play this
idea to chase the bishop but in this
particular case it's not very good
because after Bishop g3 he goes Knight
h5 and now white to play can you find a
tactic
that you will win upon at list and if
he's not careful you can check made them
actually why to play that is a nice
tactic here think about it
you win upon at least
I think about it think about a deal you
will find it why to play ah no I do
think so
three-piece no it's it's it's like a
little combination out of very difficult
it's like two moves try to see the try
to find a loose piece interest if you're
trying to find a tactic first thing you
do is you look for a loose piece which
piece for black it's unprotected the
night right so think about it what can
you take advantage of that since the
night is unprotected take the pawn okay
excellent Knight takes e5 for a moment
it seems like wait a minute why did you
sacrifice the night he takes the night
we take the night white is up upon and
not only that now King is very weak so
this is almost like a winning position
for you so then you can Knight f6 Bishop
e2 you can just follow it up with h4 and
you have you know this excellent
position you can castle to the Queen
side and if opponent is not careful he
takes on g3 then we move the Queen
checkmate
and believe me this this happened before
many games have been won like this
especially in a quick glitzy but it's
games opponent you know may not realize
this and at least when you play ninety
five you will win upon and most likely
the game of course I'm not expecting a
strong opponent to fall for this but he
doesn't it doesn't hurt me to play Queen
c2 here it's you know maybe it's a 1%
chance but you never know I've walked a
couple of blood schemes you know even
the tournament game I think about
against 2250 he missed this tactic and
he didn't get made it but he lost the
last a pawn in the game so it happens
you know you can really get this idea so
so here we realize that he cannot play
this okay I want you to pay close
attention because after I show you this
game
we're going to go over it and you're
going to be finding all the moves for
white okay so now he played Queen c7 now
now what's the most logical move here in
this position for White Castle short
castle because you don't want to Castle
queenside because sometimes in a
positions like this it's you know
something you don't know where to Castle
but because if you cancel to the Queen
side you may think oh I can try to push
the edge panel attack but it's not going
to be easy because now he can try to
play a six b5 he will try to attack your
king so this is not very good so you
play positional okay because this system
smiths off Petrossian system is just you
play positionally first you get small
advantage in the opening and try to
develop this advantage do something
bigger
Knight 85 now we need to develop our
major pieces our rooks where do you
think the rooks belong here for white
they
raise your hand please if you have an
answer raise your hand first
yes okay which one we have two rocks
right we have to specify which rook was
two Queens rook o to D file you could do
that but the problem is now what do we
do with this one so you kind of block
that on so it's very important here to
realize which piece goes there I'll tell
you in this opening when you get this
position
you always go rook f d1 first because
this square belongs for the other rook
so remember if you play this system this
is the ideal position you want to reach
out of the opening you have this
structure minor pieces out Queen on c2
looks like this if you can get this you
at least have a slightly better position
I have my stuff played maybe close to 40
50 games in this exact position I mean
it was slightly different maybe perhaps
opponent queen was only 7 but basically
the same concept and the way you learn
more about this position is by
experience by playing it for a long
period of time so it's very important
when you choose an opening you stay with
opening given just after losing one or
two games you change the opening because
you lost try to find what you did wrong
in the opening fix that and continue
playing okay if it's a good opening of
course yeah this is a good opening this
is a doesn't involve lots of theory for
you to play against the King's Indian so
now he goes here 9f8 idea behind this
move is to open the diagonal for the
bishop another common idea in this
opening is to expand on the Queen side
and the way you play before gaining
space gaining space is very important in
general but here you also want to try to
put the pawn on c5 in some point and
that's why you want to have a problem
before protecting it so you guys Bishop
f5
attacking on the Quinn now
what do you think you can try to do here
he's trying to take the Quinn it's wide
to play he just played Bishop f5 look he
paid here he is attacking your claim
so which pawn this pawn if you advance
to this pawn you can take there is this
in-between move and then if you take he
will take the central pawn because he
has the rook and Knight so he will win
upon
okay and remember it when you play this
system you don't want to put upon only
four okay it's very important you don't
want to put the pawn only four here
because that way his Bishop is going to
get more active okay I mean unless it
will give you something you give you
something like big you win a piece then
you of course you do it but if you know
just from positional point of view we
don't want to put a pawn on e4 so I walk
win b3 and now he plays 94 activating
his knight and attacking my bishop
another very important detail is you
should never allow him to take your
bishop okay without weakening the
position of this King okay so that's why
I cannot allow him to take my bishop so
I take the knight first he takes and now
the reason we put the rooks on c1 d1
because we want to open up the position
remember rooks they lack open files so
that's why when you put the rooks in the
center you try to open some files with
rocks so I take NRC suddenly my rock is
already on open file which is good yes
Bishop takes neck is not going to be
good because Kings in the Kings Indian
this dark square Bishop is very
important ah this place yeah but then I
can take in between move and attack your
queen and then you have to move your
queen I take the bishop and White is up
two pounds so always have to look for
this in between moves okay because here
this is very strong now you attack the
Queen okay so he has to take back with a
pawn and now we have a look on open file
now in this put in this opening one of
the main ideas for white is to try to
put a pawn on c5 and then transfer this
Knight to d6 this is a very important
idea if you can manage to do that you
will have the advantage not always you
can get about in this position I managed
to do that so very important move here
for white because he is considering
taking my knight like if I play c5 he
could take and then I don't have a
knight to put on d6 so I want to do
something to avoid that and then
continue with my plan
can you find the right move here very
good that's what I played attacking the
bishop see you may not realize that he
wants to take your night and just play
quickly c5 but after knowing that you
want to bring the Knight to d6 you will
preserve the knight 92 has to go Bishop
f5 and now what's the plan
c5 move the pawn get that excellent
square for the knight on c4 and now we
also have a space advantage I'll be
controlled a very important d6 square so
now he goes here attacking the bishop I
every trait and hear my opponent realize
if he just tries to play some quiet
positional moves he's just going to be
much worse my plan is very simple 94-96
and in fact you know I'm actually
threatening to pay g4 now a trap is
bishop so this is pretty serious for
block now even though it doesn't look
like it's that bad but it's you know I
have let's say he makes just a move
after g4 he loses a bishop
so I have a serious threat now trying to
trap his bishop so he decided to get
active and you know normally Kings
Indian players they like it's active
opening so they like they like to play
active so attack attack my Bishop Bishop
g3 and look at this move Knight f4
playing very interesting
he just puts the light there and says
you can take it but if I take it it will
be a big mistake he takes back with the
palm suddenly his dark square bishop is
very active the another Bishop is active
and I have two bishops hanging at the
same time so he will win the piece back
and will have a fine position so when
opponents sacrifice a piece you have to
calculate spend extra time to see if you
should accept the sacrifice so I spent
some time I realized that I don't want
to take on f4 because that will open up
the position of this dark screw bishop
so I just go Bishop f1
we should be six attacking the Queen
can I play Bishop c4 here
know why very good see it's not easy
this is this is like you know it's not
easy to see this idea so Bishop is
pinned this would be a blunder because
it goes check and I cannot take back
with a bishop because I lose my queen I
move my king it will take my rook so you
have to be careful okay
and now I need to move my queen so I
moved to be one 94-94 you're pinning the
night yeah
so it says Queen c2 actually Queen CQ
but I believe it's a I think it's a I
played Queen B won on the game so I play
Queen B one but let me check yeah it's a
whoever in put the game into chess pace
they made a mistake I actually didn't
play Queen c2 because in this position
my pawn on before would be hanging
it's unprotected so so I played in the
game I played Queen b1
okay because I wanted to make sure my
queen is actually protecting on before
so my opponent went 95 I go Knight c4 f5
now it looks like he's about to ready to
play the move f4 and simply trap my
bishop so if I let's say I activated my
knight he just goes here I take the rook
no problem he takes because he's going
to win the bishop next so he's going to
have two minor pieces for a rock so it's
not going to be very good for me now a
strong move for white to break the
center and stop a four idea what can you
do here to break the strong pulse he has
here
well Knight takes pawn loses a piece f4
mm he takes therefore he takes therefore
he will just take HT to pass if he plays
f4 and then just shuts down the bishop
on h2 which Bishop where yeah it takes
very good very good the correct move is
a plate efore because now if he takes
now central pawns are destroyed I can
just go back 96 and take the pawn with a
9/10 he has weak bonds on g5 and e5 yeah
he actually didn't take I think he
played very interesting he played for
yes sacrificing the night but my bishop
is trapped so he's going to win the
bishop so I took he takes and night
belongs on d6 so I 196 look at fate and
very interesting position here maybe
should be strapped so I'm going to lose
the bishop and looks like he has the
control of the center so it's very
important for me to do something to
destroy his center and take advantage of
the light square weaknesses if I can
somehow you know take his life square
bishop and the d5 pawn even sacrifice an
exchange this will be a very good for me
because his light Square will be very
weak how can I do that
see this d5 pawn is very strong
that's what I played now he takes them
he takes the bishop I take back he goes
rook a to d8 and setting up a nice trap
for me do you see it if I take rook
takes define it's a blunder let's move
is losing why yes
no Bishop takes Queen takes I get what I
want I get my queen in center and his
light squares are weak rock texts night
I cannot take with a pawn because I lose
the c1 rook I cannot take with a d5
because I lose my queen so both pieces
that can capture their pinned pawn is
pinned the rook and rook is pin to the
Queen here now
so that's why I didn't take i simply
prepare this idea rook to c2 and now I'm
ready to take for example if it goes
here I would take I'm not afraid of this
one anymore because I take my rook is
protected by my queen okay when
then he just takes everything on d5 and
his upper piece he just takes Luke t5
and his upper piece so he went Lucy - he
went King h8 I could have taken at once
but I said okay let me put some more
pressure again I'm planning to take on
d5 this might seem like why am I doing
this I'm sacrificing exchange but in
just few moves you will realize that I
will get the control of the whole board
and his light squares are going to be
extremely weak without his light square
bishop because look at the palm on g5
see his light squares are weak and I can
attack the king so if the pawn was on g6
then it's a different position but with
the pollen g5 it's a huge difference his
King is very weak so he plays b6
trying to break the Queen side and put
pressure on d5 and now it's time to play
rook takes d5 he captures I capture
now he can he can take but he doesn't
have to take right away because I'm
still pin so he played Bishop f6 now in
order to force him to capture which I
want him to do I moved my queen away
because now he has to take it otherwise
I will just simply go back and I'm up
upon I will just go back here so he
takes I take and now he played Queen g7
now which piece now you need to improve
so you have all your pieces in the game
and completely dominating the board and
the light squares we're excellent now I
would like you to spend a minute or two
just to give me the evaluation of this
position because it may not seem that
clear because I'm down a change I have a
knight and upon for a rook rook is
valued 5:19 upon it for so it may seem
like I'm down upon here but what do you
think is the proper evaluation of this
position spend few minutes spend few
minutes so you can see what are the
places for me in this position
maybe there are some disadvantages too I
mean one disadvantage I'm down upon
basically if we just count a material so
if you're ready to give the proper
evaluation here just raise your hand if
you think
yes excellent that's very important Mac
you've read clean and you're working for
it his claim to fame
he has to develop more pieces actually a
friend and basically white is very
active there there are a few other
things we can mention about White's
position that it's a very strong yes
what else is very strong
protecting the King waiking I mean
waiking is extremely safe very safe he
cannot attack me but how about the
blocking
do you think blocking is very safe
uh-huh for example I could put my queen
here then I have a battery remember when
we have a queen and a bishop on the same
diagram we call that a battery and
suddenly if I can deflect this Queen I
will just go Queen takes pawn checkmate
so his King is not my king is safe his
king is not safe at all
what else you can mention his dr. Bishop
is basically trapped behind his own pawn
so it's it's ineffective I mean if you
just to compare the no comparison
between my Bishop and his my bishop is
very active and one more thing very
important you have that you can mention
past pawn exactly and it's a very strong
past pawn because with the knight on d6
very quickly this could turn into a you
know cleaning yeah quilling pawn so
anyway so in a conclusion what do you
think how much advantage White has here
big advantage small slightly better
maybe winning
well interesting bill what well
basically in a well we read it with yeah
we're not going to use the Houdini
Houdini probably will say block is
slightly Wars or something but in a
practical in a practical play I would be
very comfortable to play this against
anybody and pretty comfortable I can win
this position for white yeah pretty
count because it's a very
straightforward plan that white has here
see pawn is going forward Queen comes to
e4 so many threats and a human yeah I
mean not against the engine huh against
the engine will be difficult
yeah some kind of defense maybe engine
will hold but against human I will be
very comfortable against almost alien
gets any employment actually so why it
is a big advantage here plus over - if
you're familiar with the chess symbols +
/ - this is the evaluation ok + - in
road means white is winning + / equal
that means white is slightly better + +
/ - this is the assessment of the
position means white has a big advantage
which should be developed into winning
advantage ok if you play precisely so
now very difficult to find a move for
black so he plays Bishop e7 he says ok
at least I should try to exchange this
Knight get rid of this Knight so maybe I
can you know reduce some material and I
have extra exchange but now I'm winning
the second pawn how can you win a second
pawn then you already have a bishop and
two pounds
well you don't want to take right away
because he will take take and take your
pawn you will lose your C pawn remember
this is a very important part we don't
want to lose that pawn
why to play s
yes absolutely that's what I play 95
attacking the Queen he goes Queen f6
take the bishop take the pawn rook get a
tempo and remember the chest temples are
very important you take upon attack you
get a tempo now you place Queen f6 can I
take the third panel in g5 it's not a
good idea
well think first first think if there is
no you know if you don't see you you
know what you can do then you should
take third pawn right but do you see the
problem I think we have a piece that is
overworked do you know what overworked
piece means excellent overloaded
basically usually if one piece is doing
too many things this piece can be
deflected and here if you take the pawn
what can you do
rook takes Bishop deflecting the Queen
he moves away now black is suddenly
winning okay so I have to be very
careful even in the winning positions
you have to be careful you miss a tactic
like this it's over okay same thing
Queenie four move you suggested you see
the problem first of all he can take
your pawn with check but the main
problem is he takes your bishop and it
wins the game so remember the queen is
overworked so now I need a good move
here for white you find a good move here
for white then you're winning
it's the game ended in just few more
moves
it's possible more but no I don't play
clear okay well we just talked about
that 24 he takes the bishop so the
problem is the bishop okay queen is
perfect broke everything is fine but the
problem is the bishop it's not placed
very well because he's just constantly
putting pressure very good move Bishop
see - yes
not only you keep the bishop on a strong
diagonal you also stop him from checking
okay so he cannot come to the background
they check you and you keep the bishop
here to put pressure here and now I'm
ready to win the third one on g5 so he
played g6 but now creates another
weakness the pawn on h6 is weak
what do you do to take advantage of that
weakness
Ruki six check king h2 threatening
threatening on h6 so he plays rook f6
trying to exchange the rooks and more
pieces he can exchanged better for black
here but now why to play can you find a
winning move here
think about it don't rush I actually
made the move that and after that he
resigned but in fact there is a move
that is even stronger than the mobile
plate okay so I mean you make a move
your opponent resigns but then you
analyze afterwards with the computer
it's a so that's not the best move you
made there was something better here be
excellent strongest move is Queenie four
and now you're threatening checkmate
that he cannot stop if he moves the rook
back you take on h6 with a check if they
move the rook up checkmate in two rookie
a check he comes up checkmate
when here then we can go check
maybe check I don't know which route you
want to take okay let's take this fast
and mate them here then queen h7 mate so
so basically Queen e4 and that's winning
also but let's see if you can find a
move that I played which is also very
strong I think I don't think after a
four he will resign so you need to make
a move that creates some kind of threat
strongest one is Queenie four but the
more I played also is pretty strong
he wants to take your rook bishop I'll
help you with the bishop Bishop is doing
an excellent job I'm happy with my
bishop
see I think you're too focused on trying
to checkmate exactly you push the pawn
and now you say okay I want to push it
again Queen so if it takes he resigned
here but let's see why he resign because
it could take I take now I have a two
treads push and take so the only way he
can start these two threads is to play
Queen g7 and now what do you do push the
pawn sacrificing but it's a deflection
deflecting the Queen because he has to
take it otherwise you Quinn now check
take the pawn check you cannot go back
with a checkmate he goes here
check with the bishop from b3 and he's
in a meeting net has to play Queen f7
and you check first you go see it's mate
it goes to h8 then you just go take out
checkmate
so I played c6 and Bachmann's are
winning and he resigned here so this was
a positional game and this shows a new
system for you that it's it's not I
don't think there are any books or
written on this or anything so it's very
limited material out there on this
system but if you want to learn this
definitely its I highly recommend to
play and learn and play this against
Kings Indian defense for Gil there are
two games against him I played them
twice this is f o y g e el this was 2005
minneapolis HP global tournament so it's
in database but again there are two
games i played against them the other
game is also very interesting but that's
for the next time i will show you the
other game also with him because he's an
expert of Kings Indian defense database
everything is correct but move numbers
there is a moment in a game looks like
in the database they made a mistake when
they input it so in this position okay I
didn't play Queen c2 I pay queen b1 move
21 its Queen it's everything same but
queen is on b1 because I needed to have
my queen here to protect this okay so
again it's a very interesting system to
play and it's possible a lot of players
and they're not going to be very
familiar with the system because not
that many games has been played you have
to really do some research to find out
even a lot of players I'm not even
familiar with you know the name and
everything of this so it's a Smith's log
Petrossian system in the Kings India
where we basically control the center by
putting the pants on c4 and d4 but we
don't push the pawn on e4 okay so let's
go over the first few moves again
d4 Knight f6 C 4690 Bishop g7 9 f3
we should get always get the bishop out
first okay and don't push me for e3 this
is what you want to get okay this is the
that system and then we go Bishop e2
Queen goes on c2 important and you want
to reach this position rook on rook F d1
rook AC 1 and now this is a perfect
setup here and you want to play B for
exchange only 5 put the pawn on c5 and
remember that you need to reroute this
Knight to d6 ultimate goal pawn on c5
after take take only from pawn on c5 92
94 96